Estoy seguro de que la gran mayoría de vosotros
habéis escuchado eso de que la Iglesia Católica
está de capa caída.
Qué es muy arcaica, que se ha quedado fuera
de juego y que el Islam le está comiendo
terreno en todo el mundo.
Y bueno, no podemos decir que esto sea del
todo falso en el caso, por ejemplo, de Europa,
históricamente el gran bastión de esta región.
Sí, es verdad, el catolicismo sigue siendo
muy importante en la vieja Europa.
No hay más que echar un vistazo a este mapa:
Como podéis ver, en países como Polonia
o Croacia más del 80% de su población se
considera católica.
Y en países como Italia, España o Francia
este porcentaje supera el 60%.
Claro que luego el porcentaje de católicos
practicantes es mucho más pequeño.
Por ejemplo, en España hablamos de menos
del 19% de la población.
Sea como sea, Europa ya no es el epicentro
del catolicismo mundial.
Con el aumento de la población mundial, ha
pasado de albergar el 66% de toda la población
católica del mundo en 1910 a solo el 25%
cien años después.
Y esta es una tendencia que no parece que
vaya a parar.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en esta gráfica.
En España, uno de los países históricamente
más católicos de Europa, la tendencia es
muy clara: cuanto más jóvenes, menos creyentes.
Pero ¡ojo!
No solo entre los católicos, esto ocurre
entre todas las confesiones religiosas.
Por eso, no es de extrañar que la Santa Sede
esté preocupada por el futuro del catolicismo
en Europa y, por supuesto, también en el
resto del mundo.
Si se queda sin fieles, ya no tendrá razón
de ser.
En términos empresariales, tendrá que echar
abajo la persiana.
Ojo, un apunte.
Estamos en VisualPolitik, este no es un vídeo
sobre la fe, ni para bien ni para mal.
Nuestro objetivo pasa por analizar lo que
está ocurriendo con una de las religiones
más importantes del mundo, indagar en su
futuro y descubrir que repercusiones políticas
pueden tener todos estos cambios.
Dicho esto, y como curiosidad, nunca confundáis
a la Santa Sede con la Ciudad del Vaticano.
Ya os hemos explicado alguna vez la diferencia
entre ambos en este canal, y se podría resumir
en esto:
C1(“La expresión Santa Sede se refiere
al conjunto constituido por la autoridad,
la jurisdicción y la soberanía conferidas
al papa y a sus sucesores para dirigir la
Iglesia Católica en todo el mundo” – Sara
Susana Pozos Bravo, doctora en Relaciones
Internacionales, Unión Europea y Globalización
por la Universidad Complutense de Madrid,
2017.)
Y, la Ciudad del Vaticano es, básicamente,
un Estado que se creó en 1929 para darle
una identidad territorial a la Santa Sede,
lo que, además, le ha facilitado establecer
relaciones con otros países y estar presente
en organizaciones internacionales, como la
ONU.
Y, os estaréis preguntando: ¿quién manda
aquí?
Vale, es cierto, el Papa es la cabeza de la
Santa Sede, y por eso también lo es del Vaticano
y de la Iglesia Católica.
Pero, ¿creéis que él solo puede dirigir
todo el cotarro?
En absoluto.
Por eso se apoya tanto en el servicio civil
del pontificado, como en la famosa Curia Romana.
Y, ¿qué es esto que suena tan elegante?
Pues, en resumen, un conjunto de Congregaciones,
tribunales, Pontificios Consejos y, lo más
importante, la Secretaría de Estado.
La Secretaría de Estado es crucial para la
imagen y las relaciones de la Santa Sede con
el mundo, porque es la que se encarga, básicamente,
de su política exterior.
Y, en un momento en que la Iglesia Católica
no parece atravesar su mejor momento, el Papa
va a necesitar un secretario de Estado fuerte.
Por eso, cabe preguntarse, ¿qué está haciendo
El Vaticano para recuperar la influencia de
la Santa Sede en el mundo?
¿Qué futuro tiene el catolicismo?
¿Qué ocurre con la diplomacia vaticana?
¿Es posible que Europa esté siendo sustituida
por otra región como auténtico epicentro
de la Iglesia de Pedro?
Queridos amigos, amigas, hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
T1(LA MADRE DE TODAS LAS DIPLOMACIAS)
¿Qué país creéis que fue el primero en
tejer una auténtica política diplomática?
Estoy seguro de que muchos estaréis pensando
en algún país europeo como España o Francia.
O quizás incluso en alguna histórica potencia
asiática como China.
Pues…
Craso error.
La diplomacia moderna no comenzó con ningún
Estado, sino con la propia Santa Sede.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se estima que
empezó a mantener relaciones diplomáticas
entre los siglos IV y V.
Y no solo eso, ¿sabéis quién fundó la
primera escuela diplomática del mundo?
Exacto, ¡también fue la Santa Sede!
Pero esta vez un poco más tarde, en 1701.
Es decir, cuando hablamos de la Santa Sede,
no solo hablamos de la Iglesia, también de
un histórico y poderoso aparato político.
No obstante, la Santa Sede y su influencia
en el mundo no ha sido un camino de rosas,
a pesar de su larga y extendida experiencia.
Desde luego, ha habido momentos para el olvido.
(Ya fuera por el Concilio de Nicea I en el
325 d.C. o por la presencia de apocrisiarios
acreditados de la Santa Sede en la Corte Imperial
de Bizancio en el 453 d.C., la diplomacia
de la Santa Sede es considerada no solo la
más antigua del mundo, sino también una
de las más poderosas e influyentes.
No obstante, el poder de los papas y de la
Santa Sede ha sufrido varios golpes: desde
la Paz de Westfalia de 1648, que le otorgó
un poder mayor a los Estados-nación europeos
y a los monarcas, pasando por el desprecio
a los poderes del Papa por parte de Napoleón
Bonaparte, y llegando a la disolución de
los Estados Pontificios en 1870.
La Iglesia Católica ha llegado a estar verdaderamente
contra las cuerdas ante el avance del poder
de los Estados modernos.
A esto, además, se le unen las críticas
por su inacción en momentos clave, limitándose
en muchas ocasiones a lanzar solo declaraciones
condenatorias.
Fue algo que se denunció durante la Primera
y la Segunda Guerra Mundial y, también, ahora
durante la guerra en Ucrania.
Sin embargo, también ha recibido grandes
elogios por su papel en el fin de la Guerra
Fría, por ejemplo, durante el papado de Juan
Pablo II.)
Vamos, que como os decía, el camino de la
Santa Sede no ha sido un camino de rosas que
digamos.
Pero, aun así, han logrado establecer vínculos
con la inmensa mayor parte de los países
del mundo.
De hecho, son tantos los países en los que
hay nuncios - diplomáticos del Vaticano - que
nos resulta mucho más fácil señalar a los
12 países con los que no tiene relaciones
diplomáticas establecidas, tanto por ser
musulmanes como comunistas.
Y es que aquí tenemos que tener en cuenta
que la Santa Sede parte con una ventaja importante:
su diplomacia se basa, sobre todo, en sus
redes de ayuda.
Ya sea construyendo hospitales como escuelas
o comedores sociales, la Iglesia Católica
muchas veces sustituye lo que habitualmente
son responsabilidades del Estado, especialmente,
claro está, en los países más pobres.
Y eso, eso es algo que suele traducirse en
mucha influencia social.
Por ejemplo, en la capital de Burkina Faso
encontramos el centro educativo Santa Vicente
María, que proporciona educación a más
de 400 chicas jóvenes sin recursos.
Otro ejemplo lo podemos encontrar en Turkana,
Kenia, donde han construido escuelas preescolares
y orfanatos, además de programas de ayuda
a enfermos, ancianos y discapacitados.
Como estos casos hay miles por todo el mundo,
y esto, lógicamente, ha hecho que la Iglesia
Católica gane mucha simpatía entre los más
vulnerables y, por supuesto, también entre
los Estados a los que ayuda.
Y no solo eso.
Luego está también la capacidad de mediación
que tiene la Santa Sede.
Por ejemplo, Juan Pablo II medió entre Argentina
y Chile para evitar una guerra inminente por
la soberanía de las islas del Canal de Beagle.
O, sin ir más lejos, el Papa Francisco medió
entre Obama y Raúl Castro para relajar las
tensiones entre Washington y la Habana y que
lograr que ambos gobiernos liberaran algunos
presos que tenían del otro país.
Y luego están las campañas…
La Santa Sede participa en muchas campañas
políticas a nivel internacional.
Por ejemplo, para reclamar la libertad de
culto, contra la pobreza y ahora con el Papa
Francisco están metidos en la lucha contra
el cambio climático.
[Será cosa de los tiempos.]
Pero, sin duda, hay un mensaje del Papa Francisco
que ha hecho que la simpatía por él, especialmente
en el mundo en desarrollo, se haya disparado.
Atentos.
Exacto.
Queridos amigos, amigas, a todos los reclamos
del Papa Francisco contra el consumismo y
por la lucha contra el cambio climático,
ahora también se suma un discurso claramente…
Anti-Colonial.
Fijaos.
Ahora bien, ¿y si os dijera que estas palabras
no son casuales?
¿Qué esta puede ser la mejor baza para el
futuro de la Iglesia Católica?
¿Sorprendidos?
Pues prestad mucha pero que mucha atención.
T2(EL NUEVO HUB RELIGIOSO DEL CATOLICISMO)
Al comienzo de este vídeo ya hemos dicho
que hay una especie de sensación general
de que la Iglesia Católica no atraviesa sus
mejores momentos, que está de capa caída,
vaya.
Y desde luego los datos que eso es exactamente
lo que está ocurriendo en Europa.
Ya os hemos contado cómo el viejo continente
hace tiempo que dejó de ser la región con
el mayor número de católicos.
Pero…
Os hago una pregunta, ¿sabríais decirme
cuál es la región con mayor población católica
de todo el mundo?
No, no es África, sino América Latina.
Un 28% de los 1360 millones de católicos
que hay en el planeta tierra viven en esta
región.
Hablamos, por tanto, de unos 380 millones
de personas.
Y, pensadlo bien, teniendo en cuenta su pasado
colonial bajo el Imperio español, no resulta
nada raro.
Pero ¿y si os dijera que el catolicismo se
ha estancado en América Latina?
¿Y si os dijera que hoy por hoy la Iglesia
Católica tiene puesta toda su atención en
África?
Y os preguntaréis, ¿en África?
¿Por qué?
Pues…
Muy simple, las tasas de crecimiento de población
católica en África son muy superiores a
las de América Latina y, por supuesto, también,
a las de Europa.
Y, ¿a qué se debe este crecimiento?
Pues a lo que ya os hemos contado antes: a
la labor social que lleva a cabo la Iglesia
Católica en el continente, tanto construyendo
las escuelas que os hemos dicho en Burkina
Faso o Kenia, como hospitales y programas
de ayuda para los más desfavorecidos.
Pero ¡ojo!
Pensar que este crecimiento se debe única
y exclusivamente a los logros de la Iglesia
Católica en el África subsahariana sería
un tremendo error.
Hay un factor absolutamente decisivo en la
expansión del catolicismo en esta región.
¿Tenéis alguna idea de cuál puede ser?
3,2,1…
¡Exacto!: el crecimiento demográfico.
Como podéis ver, desde 1960, la población
en el continente africano no ha parado de
crecer, desde los escasos 250 millones de
entonces hasta los más de 1.300 millones
en la actualidad.
Y esa tendencia no va a cambiar.
La tasa de fertilidad en África supera los
4 nacimientos por mujer.
Por eso, la ONU lo tiene muy claro: para el
año 2050, África tendrá más de 2.400 millones
de habitantes, lo que supondrá el 25% de
la población mundial.
¿Os dais cuenta lo que esto puede suponer
para la Santa Sede?
¿Os dais cuenta de que esto puede conllevar
una enorme expansión del catolicismo?
Desde luego, las proyecciones sobre el aumento
de la población cristiana en el continente
estoy seguro de que emocionan al Papa Francisco:
Y hablamos de solo 5 países.
Según el Pew Research Center, el número
de cristianos, se doblará en países como
Nigeria y se triplicará en países como Tanzania.
Estos 5 países estarán entre los 10 países
con más población cristiana de todo el mundo.
Y, por supuesto, la religión cristiana dominante
será el catolicismo.
Dicho de otra manera, que entre el aumento
de la población en África y su constante
presencia allí, es posible que la Iglesia
Católica llegue a ser más grande de lo que
nunca ha sido.
Así que eso de que está de capa caída,
pues como que no.
¿Sorprendidos?
Ya veis que a veces las cosas no son lo que
parecen.
Ahora bien, la Santa Sede parece tenerlo todo
a su favor para dominar el panorama religioso
del continente africano, pero ¿creéis que
no va a tener oposición?
Pues, como ya os podéis imaginar, nada más
lejos de la realidad.
Atentos.
T3( OPOSICIÓN MUSULMANA Y DEMONIOS INTERNOS)
Como en toda lucha por el poder o la influencia,
siempre que hay un actor emergente también
hay competencia.
Y este es justo el caso de la Santa Sede en
África, ya que tiene en frente a la religión
con más fieles de todo el mundo: el Islam.
Por suerte, las cruzadas ya quedaron en el
pasado, así que no esperéis ninguna guerra
sin cuartel por el control de la fe.
Sin embargo, la Iglesia Católica se va a
tener que enfrentar a un Islam que está muy
arraigado en gran parte del continente, que
también espera expandirse y que puede contar
con varias ventajas.
El Islam es la religión más profesada del
mundo y la segunda más profesada en toda
África después del cristianismo, con casi
600 millones de musulmanes.
De esta forma, y tal como ocurre con el catolicismo
en el África subsahariana, el Islam también
está consiguiendo avanzar en esta región
desde el norte de África, que es abrumadoramente
musulmán.
En este caso, la vertiente del Islam más
practicada en el continente es el sufismo.
Ya os hemos hablado en este canal de esta
rama del Islam, que se centra en la vida espiritual
y en la búsqueda de una relación más mística
con Alá desde un prisma mucho más individual.
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que l sufismo ha
estado perdiendo terreno durante el siglo
XXI a manos de la versión más radical del
Islam: el salafismo, que si recordáis bien,
defiende la pureza de la doctrina religiosa
y la textualidad del Corán, la Sunna, la
Yihad, y la gran mayoría de hádices, que
son los mensajes atribuye a Mahoma y que ordenan
muchos aspectos de la vida.
Las salafistas rechazan frontalmente al resto
de religiones e incluso al resto de vertientes
del propio islam, como es el caso del propio
sufismo
Desde luego, esto supone un gran reto para
la Iglesia Católica.
No tanto por la vertiente sufí, con la que
tiene una batalla mábs bien teológica y
argumental para conseguir más adeptos, sino
sobre todo por la vertiente salafista.
Una rama del Islam que nos deja noticias como
está:
N1(Nigeria sospecha que el Estado Islámico
mató a 40 personas en una iglesia católica)
(Cristianos de Burkina Faso asesinados en
un ataque a una iglesia.
BBC)
Terrible.
Claro que los problemas no solo vienen desde
fuera.
La Iglesia Católica también tiene que tener
cuidado con una vertiente mucho más ortodoxa
y conservadora del catolicismo, cuyas raíces
son muy profundas en África.
Algunos de sus máximos exponentes, como el
cardenal guineano, Robert Sarah, ha llegado
a equiparar al Daesh con cualquier cosa que
pueda sonar a ideología de género.
O también es el caso de Peter Kodwo Appiah
Turkson, que llegó a equiparar a los homosexuales
con los pedófilos.
De hecho, esta posición abiertamente contraria
a las personas homosexuales ya se ha trasladado
recientemente a la política y a la legislación
en un país de mayoría católica como es
Uganda.
N3(Ley contra la homosexualidad en Uganda:
Cadena perpetua por decir que eres gay.
BBC)
(Uganda anti-homosexuality Bill: Life in prison
for saying you´re gay.
BBC)
Y, claro, estas posturas chocan de manera
frontal con las nuevas tendencias que está
marcando el Papa Francisco en la Santa Sede:
N4(Papa Francisco dice que leyes que criminalizan
a las personas LGBT son un “pecado” y
una injusticia)
Como podéis ver, la Santa Sede se enfrenta
tanto a una oposición exterior que, en algunos
casos, es muy radical y violenta, como la
de los salafistas, como también a una Iglesia
Católica africana mucho más ortodoxa que
la de Roma, lo que hace improbable que vayamos
a ver, al menos por el momento, un Papa africano.
Pero lo que sí es indudable que veremos es
la creciente influencia de la comunidad católica
africana en el mundo: acompañado de un enorme
crecimiento demográfico, el catolicismo sigue
creciendo allí como en ningún otro lugar
del mundo.
Por eso, aunque en Europa esté perdiendo
terreno frente al laicismo de los Estados
y al creciente ateísmo social, sobre todo
entre las nuevas generaciones, en África
la Santa Sede está encontrando su nuevo espacio
protagonista.
Así que, no es sensato decir que la Iglesia
Católica está de capa caída.
Simplemente, está reorientándose, y es muy
posible que dentro de unos años veamos una
Iglesia Católica más fuerte que nunca y
en franca expansión.
Pero llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para
ti: ¿creéis que África se convertirá finalmente
en el centro del catolicismo mundial?
¿Veis posible un renacer del catolicismo
en Europa o una reactivación en América
del Sur?
¿Puede la lucha entre el catolicismo y el
Islam en África tener consecuencias más
graves?
¿Llegaremos a ver alguna vez a un Papa africano?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas,
así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.